do it on camera no no no no if it's on
camera we're not doing an interview why
we'll explain why how do you feel about
that influence that you have you better
be careful we're coming for your
children there buddy about Maring Nation
yes I'm going to do going you're going
to resign I'm going I've been answering
your question you answer mine it's
actually not my job to answer your
questions thank God for talk TV is not
only the home of common sense it's the
only place where you get the
[Music]
truth on TV on Radio and on your
smartphone this is talk
[Music]
TV tonight up appears Morgan on sensor
soel braan is sacked after whipping up
the mobs who brought shame to our
streets David Cameron is back in
government has Richie sunak taken charge
or just buried the conservatives will
debate as peaceful Palestine protests
were mared by Shocking displays of
brazen anti-Semitism I thought to
Chelsea's co-owner Jonathan Gold
and the former labor leader Jeremy
Corbin who spoke out that
[Music]
March live from the news building in
London this is Pierce Morgan uncensored
good evening from London welcome to PE
Morgan uncensored soel braan poured fuel
on the Flames of national tensions
before Saturday's Pro Palestine March it
gave a green light to the morons who
came to London on the false pretext the
Senate half was under attack she
effectively told the public they
couldn't trust the police those who came
looking for a fight did so with her
apparent blessing well scenes like this
were un were predictable inevitable and
entirely her
[Applause]
[Music]
fault we Prim Minister richy soon now is
been criticized as week for letting
bravman get away with repeated outbursts
that was specifically engineered to
cause controversy critics say he's risk
averse managerial not a leader but by
sacking ran and bringing David Cameron
back into government he certainly
changed that narrative judging by how
enraged labor supporters are about his
return I'd say they probably fear that
it's a rather smart move but if part of
the plan was to overshadow Bran's
sacking or bad luck we won't forget that
she abandoned her duty to keep this
country safe she's reckless in the
extreme to criticize the police ahead of
the most controversial public
demonstration in years she had to go as
I said on this show but that doesn't
mean the police all the pro Palestine
supporters are immune to criticism last
week I interviewed Douglas Murray
exchange it's now been viewed many
millions of times around the world a lot
of people focused on this
exchange okay well here's a challenge
Piers if you decided to go on some kind
of March and in week one you discovered
that you had the BNP along your side
calling for instance for the murder of
all black people would you not Wonder
whether or not you should go on week two
and would you not drop out by about week
three I'd have thought so I would well
you asked a very pertinent question and
the answer is yes as I said I would many
thousands of people marched peacefully
to support Palestine this weekend they
have every right to do so a democratic
country they serious about Free Speech
but let's be clear among those crowds
were some hateful racist and blatant
anti-semites many people again chanted
this from the river to the Sea
[Applause]
that's unacceptable from The River To
The Sea Calls for the complete
eradication of Israel there any doubt
about their intent listen to this guy
why every so many hundred years the
Zionist get slaughtered because Hitler
knew how to deal with these people
they probably made a program so they can
create a a state of Israel in the
expense of Palestinian Muslims
blood well it's disgraceful isn't it
among the crowds there were many
offensive placards this woman marched
proudly around with a star of David
mocked up as a swaser another sign
showed a Jewish snake suffocating the
world a familiar nacy Trope these men
showed up in Hamas headbands there were
many more examples we' all seen them
protesters have every right to
demonstrate against Israel's response to
the terror attacks on October the 7th
I've said that repeatedly but we can't
allow this unfettered anti-Semitism on
our streets why didn't other protesters
step in to prevent this why do the
police seem to do nothing besides
tweeting about it afterwards I remember
when the police stepped in preemptively
to arrest Republican protesters who
tried to pick at the king's coronation I
didn't think that was right at the time
but if they could be capable of doing
that on that occasion why couldn't they
do that to the blatant anti-semites on
this occasion some of whom were
obviously glorifying terrorists and that
is a crime in this
country well I'm joined now by the
broadcaster ined to the Sunday Times
Andrew Neil uh Andrew uh so much to talk
about so little time to talk about it
but let me just get your take first of
all on the bombshell news today which we
thought was going to be swell braan
getting fired but also the extraordinary
comeback of David Cameron what's your
response to this well the government's
had trouble getting middle-aged men who
lose their jobs back into the labor
force so this is a example that shows it
can be
done um but in addition to that I think
it's look the Tory genan pool is pretty
depleted and David Cameron has stature
and experience and recognition uh he
will add to the weight of a cabinet that
is pretty lightweight he brings a wealth
of experience in foreign affairs uh to
the job uh as prime minister he knows a
lot and learned a lot about Foreign
Affairs because Foreign Affairs these
days has run inside 10 Downing Street
probably even more than it is in the
foreign office people not just foreign
ministers around the world will see them
but Prime Ministers and presidents will
see him so it's a good high-profile
appointment uh for the government will
it make any difference politically is it
a game changer no it won't I don't think
it may reassure a
few withering Tories in the blue wall
that they haven't the government hasn't
given up on them but it isn't going to
affect the result of the election there
is no election in British Democratic
history that has been affected by who
the foreign secretary is what about the
removal of SW bravman does that denote
that Rishi sunak a wants to instill
Authority on his cabinet and she clearly
breached that Authority but secondly
that he's moving the party perhaps
slightly more to the center and is not
so bothered anymore about about
appeasing the right-wing of the party
well I think the idea that Richie sunite
was on the the right of the party was
always mistaken he's basically a non-
ideological
technocrat uh and a fiscal conservative
um which is what David Cameron was
George Osborne his Chancellor was too
he's pretty much in the mainstream of
conservative thinking I think the main
reason wasn't even ideological with s
bra I mean you know Linton Crosby the
great uh Australian election strategist
said that politicians have got to
realize they're not pundits that's your
job pi and my job we're not politicians
we're pundits they're not pundits
they're politicians and S braan had
basically become a pundit yeah rather
than running the home office doing
something about what was concerning her
she was writing articles for the times
and giving interviews no prime minister
can tolerate that for long Mr sunak is
not thought to be a strong leader so he
had to show the smack of firm government
in making a change and he did as soon as
he got the remembrance uh weekend out of
the way talking about that weekend the
big Pro Palestinian March obviously
there were a bunch of yobs who turned up
as well which was entirely predictable I
think after all the incendiary rhetoric
of the few days before but putting that
to one side there General agreement that
they their behavior was appalling what
do we do about big marches 300,000
people it's estim here where the
majority of them are genuinely marching
it appears peacefully and for peace they
want to ceasefire in Gaza but they are
uh joined by a not insignificant number
of people who are blatantly spewing
anti-semitic tropes or chants or
pro-hamas uh regalia in some cases what
do we do about this well I think it was
a Pity that the March took place on
Saturday but I wouldn't have banned it
and didn't want to ban it in the end the
right to protest is a democratic right
and that's a right that can be exercised
whether we approve or disapprove indeed
it's easy to approve of protesters who
are are protesting things of which we
approve uh it's more difficult but more
important to allow them to protest when
they're protesting of things that we
don't approve of so if the organizers
really wanted it to go ahead I think it
was a right to allow it to go ahead I
don't think they did their call was any
good it wasn't necessary to have done it
on Saturday there's been four marches
already there are plenty of weekends to
come between now and Christmas to have
more but that was their choice and the
main violence the main yobbish Behavior
came from the hard right um who turned
up around the Senate up and Downing
Street there they were the real thugs
there however there was an element to
that March to the pro Palestine March
which was very unsavory and you touched
on it and you monologue at the beginning
and I think you know there's a right to
protest but protesters also have
obligations and their obligation is to
stay within the law and within the
bounds of democratic legitimacy and
proper protest and I'm afraid
anti-Semitism and race hatred and
shouting yead and a clear context of
wiping Israel out is not acceptable and
the police will need to get much tougher
on that and leave the bulk of the
peaceful demonstrators to get on
exercising the Democratic rights yeah
completely agree and janil as always I
concur thank you very much indeed for
joining me thank you I appreciate uh
with me in the studio is a journalist
and columnist at being standard Emily
Sheffield and Associate editor at the
mirror Kevin McGuire well let me let me
start with you because in your other
life you're David Cameron's
sister-in-law did you know about this
bombshell coming down the line no I
think they managed I they managed to
keep this incredibly quiet uh it didn't
leak which is kind of I mean unprecedent
kind of incredible actually Le yeah um
and yeah I was as shocked as anyone when
I got the news this morning cuz he
always said he's not going to come back
to Frontline politics it wouldn't be
right he said is it right that he's
doing it I think it I think it is right
he is someone who really does believe in
serving his country however many there
there are cynics out there about
politicians there are still a great deal
of politicians who do go into politics
to serve their country and David is most
definitely one of them I think it it is
it is it is a a good move by Rishi sunak
he's got someone with some serious
gravitas and experience in the job of
foreign secretary at a time which we
cannot doubt I mean we've just been
talking about the march on on Saturday
what's going on in Gaza what's going on
in Israel what's going on in Ukraine
which is been wiped off the front pages
which is a terrible thing because guess
who is who guess who the opportunity is
given to Putin David spent time with
Putin he spent time with Netanyahu and I
think what rushi sunak is doing here and
everyone can talk about whether it's you
know he's appeasing the blue wall and
trying to win votes I think he's
actually trying to to govern I mean he
is prime minister and SW bravman was not
governing she was acting like aor she
was totally using her position to
advertise for the next job I thought she
had two problems Kevin one she wasn't
the brightest tulip in the patch I mean
her her analogy of the Northern Ireland
marches for example so there's total
ignorance but secondly just openly
defying her boss you can't tolerate that
as a boss in sux position I do actually
think just judging by Labor's reaction
that they're a little bit concerned
about this appointment it's smart smart
polies isn't it look it's it said rishy
sunak turned to David Cameron because he
couldn't persuade William hay who used
to be a foreign secretary to take the
job but I'm not against experienced
people are you but the re no I value
experience as long as you still got
enthusiasm but I think what richy sunak
has done is a good idea for labor that's
why they're cocka hoop because they
remember David Cameron with austerity
running down the NHS benefit Cuts what
happened to public services and he lost
the 2016 referendum which he called
himself as a tactical maneuver and he
lost it so they will now be able to say
rishy sunak presents himself as I'm the
prime minister of change and his
conference speech only last month he
attacked 30 years of old consensus that
encompassed labor and David Cameron now
he's got him by his side because the
Tory Talent pool as Andrew Neil said is
is drained and he will not be able to
present himself as a fresh-faced new
prime minister committed to CH you can't
do it look it's back to no future
actually I'm really sorry Kier starmer's
front bench Shadow front bench has got
people like IET Cooper in IET Cooper is
hardly a fresh face good cabinets have a
mix of very experienced people and and
and fresh blood and sunak has got that
you are thee Minister who lost Europe
you lost Europe now you're foreign
secretary a joke he won two elections
and K starma I'm sorry given what we've
just seen on the television is the man
who backed Corbin so labor have got that
we've got Corbin K we've actually got
Jeremy Corbin coming in Emily can try
and deflect like that but the fact the
fact is the fact is people will now see
it's the same old conserv when Sun's
entire strategy was I am the change you
are voting for me the change no you're
not you got your M dodgy Dave here
dodgy Dave is her brother-in-law I know
but I I like Emily but that doesn't mean
I have to like all you call him dodgy
Dave I don't call
him let me let me ask you Kevin about
Jeremy Corbin he's not been on the show
before he's coming in live tonight with
Len mcclusky to my surprise and and
they've agreed to come in despite all
the news this breaking which may have
changed their minds you know where does
Corbin sit here in the labor party oh
he's a pretty much pushed away he won't
be allowed to stand as a labor MP he's
toying with standing as an independent
he's toying with standing for mayor of
London but he wouldn't be able to stand
as labor he's he's got some supporters
around the issue of uh Israel and
Palestine unquestionably but there are
others who will support the Palestinian
cause and say the Israeli response is
disproportionate but they think he gets
the tone wrong he is too
anti-israel um so now he's which which
and he was you know found to have been
presiding over a a leadership which was
deemed to be you know not helpful to
Jewish people which is a terrible thing
for a labor leader to have hanging over
him right come on we're not describing
it as not helpful to Jewish people what
was going on in the labor party was
anti-semitic that is like saying what's
happening now is not helpful to Jewish
people on those it was equality and
human commiss should be called out for
what it is yeah they said the party
responsible for unlawful acts of
harassment of discrimination while the
leadership was guilty of serious
failings I mean it was a serious job it
was a very very very damaging charge and
it was a stain on labor particularly a
party on the left that preaches equality
and respect for all it's it's kind of
what what's the one question you'd ask
Corbin are you going to stand on the
general
election I would I'd say does he regret
how what he presided over when he when
he ran the labor Cardy those good
questions my job is done thank you both
of you I'm the SED next to former chair
of the Jewish Leadership Council and one
of Chelsea football club's co-owners
Jonathan Goldstein joins me live for his
thoughts on the weekend protest and the
ongoing war in Israel and
[Music]
Gaza
[Applause]
[Music]
e
welcome back to P centr I'm joined Now
by Jonathan goldon the former chair of
the Jewish Leadership Council and
co-owner of Chelsea Football Club
Jonathan great to see you uh what was
your reaction as a as a member of the
Jewish Community a leading member done a
lot of work um for the Jewish Community
what did you feel about this March at
the weekend and the March is generally
with the volume of people who are
turning up spewing anti-Semitism well
let me start by saying that the far
right who turned up on Saturday are no
friends of anyone no one welcomes that
it's hateful it's absolutely the the the
epitome of every that no one wants to
see in British Society racism at its
Forefront really that needs to be
condemned by everybody before you start
but in terms of the general rallies
obviously they' they've caused Great
concern to the Jewish Community now I am
convinced that there are a significant
number of people on those rallies that
genuinely want to see a peaceful
situation within Israel and with the
Palestinians but I'm afraid that there
are a significant number of people
encouraged by invariably by the
leadership of those rallies who are
Hamas supporting who are supporting and
and and espousing hateful and genocidal
messages on that rally and that needs to
be condemned and and the reason it
continues is because the leadership of
those rallies continues to in when you
have somebody like my next guest Jeremy
Corbin who's speaking there but not
publicly condemning those people who are
the minorities be clear but he not
publicly condemning them what would your
message to him be the message is very
simple if it was any other minority in
this country Mr Corbin would ensure that
they did not feel victimized they did
not feel bullied they did not feel
intimidated so that the Jewish Community
does not feel safe going into London
during these weekends P You're a
straightforward talking human being we
all know that from The River To The Sea
Palestine will be free where the
population of Israel is 10 million of
which 8 million almost are Jewish people
means a land free of Jewish people it
means it can mean nothing else it is a
genocidal message and the fact that it
is being encouraged by the leadership of
those rallies creates hate creates
incitement and creates a great deal of M
we've seen people blatantly saying on
camera through social media at the march
on Sat the death to the Jews I mean it's
it's not ambiguous we' seen other
chanting Jihad that's not ambiguous and
what you'll get from your next guest is
is a small denunciation but let's go
back to October 7th Mr Corbin failed to
condemn in the days following the
actions of Hamas he called for many
years Hamas his friends he thought they
were peaceloving the Jewish Community
has known for decades that these people
not just want to kill Israelis but they
want to kill Jews now I was in Israel on
the 7th of October I was there on the
day if I had been there there would have
been no discrimination between me and
anybody else
the the significant the largest number
of hostages other than Israelis are Thai
workers who are working in farms in the
south of Israel now I saw no placard at
the rally at the weekend calling for the
release of the hostages I saw none I see
no request for Hamas to unconditionally
release over 200 babies children mothers
fathers Holocaust Survivors I see none
of that okay so let me spin it around
now to the the criticism of Israel's
response I read today that one of uh
Israel's ministers was saying they think
they've got about three more weeks of
being able to wage the war as they are
before international support starts to
really
evaporate there there's going to be a
Tipping Point here because there are so
many innocent Palestinians getting
slaughtered as they go after Hamas and
of course the demographic of Gaza being
what it is so many of those are kids
look the loss of innocent life on all
sides is tragic let us start with that
position I think we all will agree that
the the the problem that I think Israel
has is that it doesn't know what else to
do and I ask you what would Britain do
what would any other civilized society
do with the infrastructure that Hamas
has built up on its border we've all
seen the pictures of the tunnels
hundreds of miles of these tunnels
Underground and if it appears to be
absolutely true that the main nerve
center of the Hamas leadership is under
a hospital but is there for you is there
a limit to this I am not on the ground
and nor are you okay you know people who
are I think right so we are relying upon
statistics given by a Ministry
controlled by terrorists so let's first
of all understand that but let me also
explain something from a very personal
perspective over 15 years ago my younger
brother with his wife and three children
immigrated to Israel I have a niece of
19 years old and a nephew in his early
20s serving in the Israeli Army I know
these children I know their contempories
they are fighting for the survival of
their
country if Hamas was to lay down their
weapons there would be peace there was
an effective peace up until 7th of
October I'm afraid if Israel lays down
its weapons there would be no Israel and
this is the way that this is now being
seen by Israel on the 7th of October
Israel lost control of its state for a
number of hours we've all seen the
pictures of places like kibot beeri and
I'm afraid that Israel has no option
than to do its utmost safely as safely
as it can within the confines and
regulations of international law to
remove the infrastructure and the
leadership of Hamas when that has
happened we can all hope and pray that
that cre Crees a basis for a peaceful
coexistence between Israel and the
Palestinians that is what Jews pray for
every single day the major prayer in the
Jewish world three times a day is to
pray for peace in the world and that's
what we all hope for that out of this we
can remove the danger to Israeli Society
we can move the danger to Palestinians
Hamas are no friends of the Palestinians
as we've seen no they're not and
hopefully lead on to a more peaceful
future Jonathan gy thank you very much
indeed I appreciate it on S next as I
said the former leader of labor party
Jeremy Corbin and Tre unionist mclusky
will be live in the
studio we're here good morning everybody
hope you well thanks for joining us
you're watching the independent republic
of Mike gra right here on talk TV
welcome to Friday night with n here on
prime time we like to speak to the
business people behind big moments good
evening I'm Pi Morgan uncensored in New
York City very impressive well
played I'm 3 days into the job what have
I done wrong and your face just starred
out at me me and you conquer time who
wins you do you know what I love about
tour today we do it all sunak sella
scon are you actually speech rating for
richy I'm so rich
frankly uh I'm going to take the side of
boozed up Brits against these pomp you
mean you're not going to support mayor
Jose L
not stop panding to the nimes to the
naysayers and The National Society for
the preservation of the habitat of the
Lesser spotted M the problem lies in the
bureaucracy it's almost like there
highly paid consults don't really know
what they're
doing the first thing they teach you in
weather school is never confuse dog
walkers with Doggers Twitter you sons of
can you please please reinstate my
account thank you there's a threat that
you'd be worried about so are you saying
that you're being overwhelmed that
you're inundated we are really working
hard for you we're just asking patients
to be patient with us are we only going
to be trusting sources like meta and
Google and Facebook and ex formly known
as Twitter where is our where is our
unbiased news going to come from Welcome
to the talk it's really great to be back
my Little Darlings kids think all they
have to do is stay at home
be silly take pictures of everything
just shut down Tik Tock then
yeah problem solved you go who's fit as
a butes do him all right but but he's
now middle class us here Tess I nearly
have empathy when I'm speaking to them I
know know you're probably going to
me
out this is talk
[Music]
TV well welcome back I'm John by the
editors of the new Anthology poetry for
the many but they're rather unlikely
anthologist former labor leader Jeremy
Corbin and former unite General
Secretary Len mcclusky well welcome to
both of you I certainly wasn't expecting
you to to grace my studio so thank you
for coming in um right Jeremy let me
start with you you were at this march on
Saturday and you were speaking there and
as you know it was a controversial March
uh I from my point I think a lot of
people there are there for the right
reasons they're there because they
genuinely believe that they want to have
a ceasefire in Gaza and stop more people
being killed I understand that but there
are people there and we've seen all the
images all over social media who are
blatant anti-semites and in some cases
blatantly supporting Hamas what do you
feel about that well they weren't taking
part in the March that was organized by
PSC and stop the war well they were
there
well well they've been I've seen them SE
images the equivalent of the crowd of 10
Cup finals came to London on Saturday to
March for peace in Gaza because they're
appalled at what's happening there and
there were people there who wanted
ceasefire there was what about the
blackards there calling releas I've
already said that calling for the
release of I've acknowledged that I'm
concerned about the ones who were
chanting death to the Jews the ones who
were wearing Hamas regalia the ones who
were Ching have been arrested by The
Police Every protest that's taken place
in London and I've been on many of them
always as a group of people there to
cause trouble they're normally dealt
with by the police don't be asking
Jeremy or the people who organized a
perfectly legitimate why shouldn't I ask
somebody who helped organize it no he
not organized speaker he was a speaker
all right well let me ask you this so
he's answered emphatically should have
been arrested you agree if they're
breaking the law and showing illegal
signs then obviously the police have to
act anybody can I just be let me just
ask you a simple question you seem to be
over concerned with with anti-Semitism
no no I did not don't put words in my
mouth I didn't say that what I said was
about to say was you seem to be
minimizing the fact that 800,000 people
one of the very biggest demonstr in our
history well 300,000 okay but I'm
minimizing your description of the size
of the crowd but I'm not minimizing as I
said that extends from Battery to Marble
Arch I said at the start the majority of
people there were for their for
well-intentioned reasons right but he
but they what do you want peer do you
want us to say that anybody engaged in
anti-Semitism we condemn out of hand
because we've been doing that both of us
all our lives what was interesting learn
was that you were emphatic that you said
they should all be arrested do you
Jeremy think they broken the law and the
police feel there's a case for it then
of course they can do that and they did
do that in some cases but but I want you
to understand the size of this
demonstration the peaceful nature of it
a very large number of Jewish people in
the Jewish block also carrying placards
calling for the release of hostages this
was a cry of all kinds of people Jewish
Muslim Hindu Buddhist Christian
everything calling for an urgent
ceasefire I think the question you
should be asking is why hasn't our
government listened to what ordinary
people are saying well because they
don't agree that there should be a
ceasefire and there are I think a very
arguable point about it which we're
going to come to my previous guest says
you haven't condemned what herass did on
October the 7th have you of course I
have on every speech and do you
unreservedly condemn at every speech
I've made I've utterly condemned the
killing of October the 7th and it was a
taking of innocent life it was totally
wrong under any circumstances you don't
bring back the tragedy of those 14400
deaths by killing 10,000 people in Gaza
you have to have a process C that leads
to a ceasefire that hopefully how do you
get do you think hamash should stay in
charge of the Palestinians decide who's
in charge your opinion wait a minute
I'll I'll tell you how you get rid of a
mass dead easy go get the Israeli
government to comply with international
law withdraw from the occupied
territories dismantle illegal
settlements and build a viable Palestine
which is the United Nations position
it's the British government's position
why would that stop Hamas behav because
there would not be a need for Hamas the
the justifies what they did on the
nothing
justifies there a bunch of Medievil
barbarians it was disgraceful but
they're not going to listen to any it's
interesting it's interesting their
Charter is a nihilistic view of Israel
and getting rid interesting it's
interesting that you always have on the
screens like many other media the war
between Israel and amass it's not a war
between Israel and the mass it's between
Israel and the Palestinian people it's
not thousands and thousands so you agree
with thousands of people women and
children being killed no I don't agree
with 1500 being killed October 7th
neither do I but but I do agree let me
explain what I do can I put something
let me explain to you to let me just
clarify my position it might be helpful
I've had lots of pro Palestinian guests
on the show as you may or may not be aw
very good I tried to be very fair but
I've been consistent about my own
opinion I think think after what Hamas
did on October the 7th it is utterly
inconceivable that Hamas remained in
power in Gaza inconceivable support
amass I'm not a friend of amass I don't
age you used to call them friends no
hang on we did you're no Ken let's get
this clear we did say that he can you
hang on a second let me just is that not
true can I say something very clearly to
which I've said many times and I said it
on Andrew Mar two weeks ago 10 years ago
10 years ago I was in a private meeting
in the house House of Commons with a
number of people who were representative
of different Palestinian groups it was
an attempt to understand their views and
to bring people together for a short
time a person who was related to Hamas
left the room and I said in a Collegiate
friendly and appropriate way as you
would at any meeting where is our friend
from Mass gone that's all I said and
that so you called her as friends no oh
come on oh come on peers you just you
just admitted how many times have you
sat in and called somebody a friend I
wouldn't say my friends from the IRA I
wouldn't say my friend from Isis I
wouldn't say my friend from Al-Qaeda
look you s my friend from a mass you
might have Jeremy you might have changed
your mind which you're perfectly
entitled to do and my understanding is
you you do regret you are obsessed
obsessed with tittl tattle of politics
of something that happens 10 years ago
why don't you why don't you instead con
you people supporting herass let me
finish give me a chance let me yeah give
me a chance let me finish how do you
think people in Palestine feel under
occupation how do you think it's like
what it's like growing I know they feel
growing up with a soldier outside your
house how do you feel how would you feel
your land was being taken put in how
would you feel if your children were
being bombed in a hospital can I answer
yeah please okay I had a Palestinian
doctor on here a few days ago who'd lost
over 30 members of his family right he
grew up on the a jabili refugee camp his
parents were displaced in 1948 and they
ended up in the refugee camp where he
then lost three of his daughters were
killed in Israeli strike on a home he
had finally got for himself he then
immigrated and has now been nominated
for the Nobel Peace Prize he was in
tears at this desk in that seat so I
don't need to be told I I've I've said
said that the way the way that Israel is
able even today to turn the tap on of
water and energy and fuel into Gaza is
wrong Palestinians should have the same
human rights as people in Israel
I'm unequivocal about but I'm also
unequivocal in my head that Hamas has to
go the question for you Len and for you
Jeremy but the question is if Israel
doesn't do it like they're doing it how
do they get rid of just give you the
answer grp you I I no no no no peer I
give you the answer before and I'm I'm
going to ask you a question do you
condemn the Israeli government for the
occupied settlements that are growing
and have been growing for decades and
are against international law do you
condemn that yes fine then the best way
to get rid of any extremism that exists
in Nations and groups is to comply with
international law and make certain that
Palestine is given a VI and I'll finish
with this question if we all believe in
a two-state solution why doesn't our
government recognize the state of of
Palestine why did they only recognize
the state of Israel I think you can only
have a hypocrisy at highest only have a
two-state solution but in this
particular part of this very long
conflict you have a situation where
Hamas now represents an existential
threat to Israel and they've repeated it
last week their spokesman from Hamas
repeatedly said when he was challenged
we want to do this again and again again
again let me ask Jeremy a question I
want to come back to this thing about do
you do what do you do to with Hamas do
you keep them in power
israela it is not from him he agrees
with the the Israeli government you
wouldn't answer I said would you keep
aass in power you wouldn't answer they
wouldn't be can you not speak for him
it's not a puppet show it's not a puppet
show L it's not a puppet show he's
allowed to answer for himself of course
he is well let him answer the reality is
the reality Jeremy all you want to do is
bully people who am I bullying you're
bullying constantly two of you okay
one's run the party in the country one's
run a major Union are you really feeling
bullied let do me a favor do me a bloody
do me a bloody favor let me come back to
Jeremy cor if I may without without you
speaking for can I put it this way would
you get rid of M can I say you can
answer my question can I say something
would you get rid of her Mass list can I
say or thank you can I say something
thank you
Israel claiming it is conducting
legitimate self-defense where is
legitimate self-defense pre-ordering the
bombing of a hospital knowing there are
children in it where is legitimate self
you've heard their argument about they
believe that Hamas and this has been
corroborated by the way by everyone from
Bill Clinton Bill Clinton is on the
record as saying that this is years ago
he's on the record as saying that Hamas
five six seven years ago fact you know
what let listen to him say it himself
heyas is really smart when they decide
to Rocket Israel they insinuate
themselves in the hospitals in the
schools in the highly populous areas I
killed myself to give the Palestinians a
state I had a deal they turned down that
would have given them all of Gaza wait
wait all of Gaza between 96 and 97% of
the West Bank compensating land in
Israel so two things then we'll come to
the second part in a moment but he's
Crystal Clear Bill Clinton in 2016 he
was President of the United States for
two terms right that Hamas were using
hospitals schools moss and others
deliberately and they don't care about
Palestinian lives they don't care about
them ask question they knew when they
did what they did on October the 7th
there was going to be a massive reaction
by Israel they knew thousands of
innocent Palestinians would die they
don't care about their people so my
question for you J which you have an
answer jery and I want you to answer
dead already how many more are there
going to be before this is over how many
more holy innocent Palestinian are going
to be killed because of isra answer my
question answer my question a ceasefire
means a cease fire that's why we're
calling both sides right would you have
said ceasefire as this is the Israeli
argument back at you would you have said
ceasefire to the Allied Forces in World
War II against the Nazis when they went
after cities like Dresden and killed
tens of thousands of people in one night
would you have said ceasefire or would
you have said you keep going until you
finish and defeat the enemy that's their
argument they're a war with a group that
wants to remove Israel completely and
kill every Jew that can get their hands
on now I've asked you repeatedly I to
rehearse everything in the Second World
War I think military targets should be
industrial and Military targets but a
lot of homes and hospital as you know a
lot of German civilians died in the
process of taking on the Nazis so my
question again and just answer this
question would you keep mass in power
it's not up to you what's your opinion
you're expressing plenty of other
opinions aren't you can you calm down a
minute can I ask you a question I'm
sorry Cal down a minute if you think a m
should stay in power calm a minute can I
ask you well I wanted to answer the
question can I ask no he can answer it
can I ask you a question it's not a
puppet show ly can I ask you why
wouldn't you say her go you are a very
strange form of interviewing am I where
you interrupt shout and your gu well you
refuse to answer my question and he
keeps trying to answer it for you no I'm
going to ask no I'm not going to ask me
a question it's not your show it's mine
and I keep asking you the same question
would you keep Hamas in power what I
said was there has to be a ceasefire a
ceasefire has to be both sides that
ceasefire will then hopefully develop
into a longer term peace well you think
Israel can do hang on a minute you think
Israel can do peace with Hamas Israel
has been talking to her mass for 20
years they can do peace with them after
after October the 7th they've been talk
listen October the 7th was abominable
and appalling that were agree and you
think Israel can do peace with people
that did that I managed to get two
sentences in between because you won't
answer my question look if you want to
have a discussion fine you want to just
shout at me that's your prog your TV
your show should her stay in power
listen what I said was a ceasefire means
a ceasefire it means both sides have to
ceasefire it means you then no you said
that should have I stay in
power it's actually you done yet it's
actually a critical question it's a
critical question are you done yet no
it's the question are you done yet
should they stay in done this country
says they're a terror group do you agree
and should they stay in listen I do not
approve support or welcome Hamas are
they a terror are they a terror group
everybody knows what they are are they a
terror group look PE say PE can we have
a discuss can we have a discussion can
you call them a terror we have a disc
you call them a terror group is it
possible to have a rational discussion
are you prepared to call h a terror
group is it possible to have a rational
disc is it possible come on answer that
question you answer it no it's my show
you answer my question you are the
terror group listen can I are they a
terror group PE can I speak answer the
question can I speak are they a terror
group PE if you let me speak are they
ter if you'll let me speak I'll say
something go on then a ceasefire means
both sides you said that are they a
terror group listen I said that because
part of the process are they a terror
group
will can we go why can't you say it
Piers can we go through what ought to be
happening just answer my question why do
you
think in the world are calling for a
ceas teror group come on answer that me
your show you've got some many opinions
why should I answer yours when you won't
answer mine why do you give out your
opinions all day and every day you don't
like a terror group yes or no you won't
let you won't like it when somebody push
back on you what I've said is I've asked
you two questions should a mass stay in
power and are they a terror group you're
refusing to answer either of them that
is very telling and you wonder not very
you wonder why people think you had a
problem with Jewish people at all what
is very tell is your inability to keep
quiet for 30 seconds to allow anybody to
answer a question on my show I ask
people questions normally they answer
them you shout at people no only when
they won't answer the question you shout
at people all the time delber you
deliberately not answer my question p i
I've explained to you how to get rid of
a m are they a terror group L of course
the terror why can't you say that hang
on hang on you've answered it should
they stay in power but do you they stay
no they won't be in power do you believe
they should they won't be in but do you
believe they should they won't be in do
you believe they should they won't I
don't believe Okay so answer my
questions it's not that difficult to say
hamash should go and they're a terror
group why can't you Jeremy answer
questions ask something about the
behavior of the Israeli Army and the
Israeli government why can't you say
that why can't you have a discussion
about how a ceasefire would come about
why can't you have a discussion about a
process for the future because you know
why which brings abouty brings about a
peace for everybody in because when I
repated not mean that the people of Gaza
when I repeatedly support Hamas when I
repeatedly ask you a mass a terror
organization and should they stay in
power and you are simply incapable of
saying that they're a terror group and
they shouldn't stay in people will draw
their own conclusions they draw their
own your conclusions how me conclude
with this uh you've done a book on
poetry it's poetry for the many I
appreciate it thank you very much
wonderful poetry from wonderful people
encouraging the working classes to
embrace and enjoy culture poetry and
music for the many I love poetry we can
agree on that good
thank you very much goodbye okay on sens
to next Douglas Murray joins me live
from Tel
[Music]
Aviv
[Applause]
[Music]
e
coming up on the independent republic of
Mike grah we're going back to the future
David Cameron's return is going to be
absolutely shocking for anybody who
thought they were voting Tori to get a
rightwing government because it ain't
going to be that way anymore we've got
Isabel oaw we've got Peter Hitchens and
loads more join us after 9:00
[Music]
p.m. welcome back I'm joined by the
author and associat of The Spectator
Douglas Mur well dougas you'd be waiting
patiently over there in Israel uh what
did you make of that extraordinary
interview um well I mean um listening to
Jeremy Corman let alone Len uh talking
about the Middle East and the way to
solve the middle east's problems is like
watching somebody trying to do brain
surgery whilst wearing boxing gloves I
mean it is so cack-handed it's just
beyond
belief nobody in this region could make
any sense of their dreams and claims and
assertions it it it everything that they
said falls apart on first analysis and
the most extraordinary thing to me was
Jeremy Corbin's Resolute refusal to
answer two simple questions should Hamas
stay in power and are they a terror
group he wouldn't do it let mclusky
answered both but Corbin was paralyzed
he he could not answer those two basic
questions but I'm afraid as you know uh
appears that's a character career trait
of Jeremy Corbin it was just the same
with Shin Fay
Ira uh he always seems to keep the door
open to Terror groups whether they are
anti-british Terror groups like The ra
or anti-israel groups like Hamas I don't
know why he feels this need he's never
been involved in any International Peace
negotiations anywhere certainly never
anywhere with any success never anywhere
with any prominence even so it's always
bizarre to hear him talking as if he's
sort of been the UN Secretary General
for the last 50 years and quite scary to
think he was nearly potentially prime
minister of his country I mean it does
beggar the question if this had happened
to us what would his reaction have been
if he's not able to say that Hamas after
what they did on October the 7th are a
terrorist organization what would have
happened if a terror organization had
killed 1500 British people on our soil
if he'd been running the
country absolutely and I and I'd add to
that I mean you know he talks about the
the importance of clarity and and being
absolutely clear on things and is very
unclear on things himself what he just
said there about the Palestinians and
Hamas and I mean they he and Len moski
talk about Palestine for instance what
do they mean by Palestine do they mean
the West Bank do they mean the West Bank
and Gaza do they mean the West Bank Gaza
and East Jerusalem like what is this
state do they mean everything in
pre-1948 or post 1948 they never say
they just talk about this non-existent
state that still doesn't exist because
for decade after decade people like them
have supported the worst possible
elements and have encouraged them in
this delusion that Israel can be
disappeared it's not going to be
disappeared and yet this delusion is
encouraged among other things among some
people in the Palestinian leadership
which is why when they're offered 99% of
a state as they have been time and time
again they say no because 99% isn't 100%
well that clip I found of Bill Clinton
from a few years ago was very telling
both in his description of what Hamas do
which they're now doing uh and also in
the fact that he had a a great
settlement there and Arafat at the last
minute screwed him just walked away
absolutely Arafat walked away as it as
his predecessors walked away time and
again uh it could all be so different
you know it could all be so different
just going back to what's happened in
Gaza since the withdrawal you know
remember the Israelis left Gaza in 2005
it was extremely traumatic for the
people of Israel because they saw
members of their own Army pulling
forcibly Jewish families from their
homes because they said that they would
give Gaza over to the Palestinians they
were ctions hamz won the elections
killed their fata Rivals and then never
had another election how can anyone
defend this group or believe they're a
legitimate government of Palestine and
the idea that there any part I tell you
one thing Piers it's very very obvious
when you're here in the in the period
after the massacres of October the 7th
it doesn't matter whether you're
right-wing or leftwing it doesn't matter
whether you're a peace niik like many of
the people who were murdered in the kots
or um a supporter of Benjamin Netanyahu
nobody in Israel believes that they can
live beside Hamas nobody no well why
would you I mean Hamas are dedicated in
their Charter to the eradication of
Israel and they've proven on October the
7th they will kill as many Jewish people
as they can get their hands on and the
Hamas spokesman only last week said they
want to do what happened October the 7th
again and again and again you can't do
peace with people with that mental I
was I was at one of the trauma hospitals
earlier speaking to some survivors of
the the October attacks I was very
struck particular by one man in his I
suppose 40s 50s um he and his family hid
in their safe room but they didn't lock
safe rooms they couldn't lock because
they were for bombs not for hamaz
terrorists coming door Todo um his
daughter managed to survive he lost both
his legs um he lost his wife died in
front of him and his daughter and he
lost his 14-year-old son and after this
man described what happened when his boy
breathed his last um he said look I'm a
leftist I've always been a leftist
Douglas just hold dougas hold your we're
just going to come off there on the show
but we're going to carry on this for our
YouTube so one second just stay with me
uh keep it uncenter we're going to keep
with Douglas Murray we're going to be
live on our YouTube channel now keep
following I'll come back to
Douglas
[Applause]
[Music]